una disuasión considerable así calificó
el primer ministro británico su plan
para combatir la migración ilegal la
política consiste en trasladar a ruanda
a las personas que llegan a territorio
británico cruzando clandestinamente el
canal de la mancha en balsa
y los que intenten saltarse la fila o
abusar de nuestro sistema no podrán
instalarse automáticamente en nuestro
país sino que serán rápida y humanamente
expulsados a un tercer país weiss safe
el plan implica que cualquiera que haya
llegado al reino unido según palabras
textuales ilegalmente desde el 1 de
enero será enviado a ruanda donde se
procesará su solicitud de asilo y en el
mejor de los casos obtendrá permiso de
residencia en ese país africano
ruanda tendrá la capacidad de recoger
decenas de miles de personas en los
próximos años ruanda es uno de los
países más seguros del mundo reconocido
globalmente por dar la bienvenida e
integrar a migrantes
el gobierno de ruanda aplaudió el
acuerdo por el que recibió unas 120
millones de libras unos 160 millones de
dólar y estadounidenses en 1994 2
millones de refugiados huyeron del país
tras el genocidio de la población tutsi
pero en los últimos años ruanda se ha
comprometido con la protección de los
solicitantes de asilo en el marco de
acuerdos con la unión africana y acnur
sin embargo distintas ong han señalado
el historial de violaciones de los
derechos humanos de kigali la
organización de tensión action alertó
que ruanda no es un país seguro otros
prevén que el plan será ineficaz
wahabíes tenemos años de evidencias de
esta misma política en australia que no
ha funcionado para frenar las llegadas
al país en busca de asilo y todo a un
alto costo para los ciudadanos
australianos
mientras aumenta el número de personas
que cruzan desde el continente europeo
al reino unido- el gobierno británico se
impacienta por cumplir su promesa del
break sheet de controlar la migración el
año pasado más de 28.000 personas
cruzaron el canal de la mancha
clandestinamente